in this lecture we developed the weak
law of large numbers loosely speaking
the weak law of large numbers says that
if we have a sequence of independent
random variables with the same
distribution then the average of these
random variables which is called the
sample mean approaches the expected
value of the distribution in this sense
it reinforces our interpretation of the
expected value as some kind of overall
average the weak law of large numbers is
the reason why polling works by asking
many people about the value of some
attribute and by taking the average of
the responses we can get a good estimate
of the average over the entire
population on the mathematical side in
order to derive the weak law of large
numbers we will first need to develop
some inequalities namely the Markov and
chebyshev inequalities both of them tell
us something about tail probabilities
suppose that a is a number then it is
reasonable to expect that the
probability that the random variable
exceeds a will be small when a is very
large but how small the Markov and
chebyshev inequalities give us some
answers to this question based only on
knowledge of the mean and the variance
of the distribution finally we will have
to deal with a technical issue the weak
law of large numbers talks about the
convergence of a random variable to a
number for this to make sense we need to
define an appropriate notion of
convergence we will introduce one such
notion that goes under the name of
convergence in probability and we will
see that in many respects it is similar
to the common notion of convergence of
numbers